this is a quick video to my friends in
the black and Latin communities I need
your guidance I need to support and your
advice on something really important but
before getting there I want to tell you
a quick story if you guys know a show
name Star Trek it first came out I think
in the 60s one of the things that was
really interesting about it was they had
a black woman as the third in command it
was lieutenant Uhura and at that time it
was strange
not just for a woman to be in a position
of power talking about the 1960s but to
have a black person in the person of
power was really radical really
different now the person who played the
tumor her out she wanted to quit the
show after the first season she had an
opportunity to go and be in a Broadway
play and that was her first love and she
told the producer Gene Roddenberry that
she was gonna quit the show a little
while later Martin Luther King showed up
on her doorstep said he was a big fan of
the show and that she couldn't quit he
told her you cannot quit because it's
too important it's too important to the
community to the black community it was
the only show that he allowed his kids
to stay up late to go and watch and for
the first time black people had
something to look up to and say hey look
this person is making it this person is
having an impact if she can do it we can
too
[Music]
I looked up and I'm a oh my god there's
dr. King they're sock to Martin Luther
King and I met him and we became great
friends and I became friends with this
family and it was a great time in my
life for me I was offered a role on
Broadway and hell and high water was not
gonna stop me only dr. King did I was
going to quit the show he said you can't
you can do it at another time but at
this sign you have an obligation I said
of what he said two of probably a
million and I have black people and
twice as many white people and a few
yellow brown orange and green people
your first on television you changed the
face of television forever he said but
right now if you leave it's as though
you were never there because you haven't
been there long now they can put some
money back up a blue-eyed blonde white
girl in there and it won't matter and I
was mad I was angry because I wanted to
go and do something and I started
thinking about it and I said it's not
about me it's not about me it's about us
and so lieutenant Ahura stayed on the
show all the way until the season was
done and then the series was done she
stayed every single season fast-forward
there was an actress by the name of
Whoopi Goldberg who you may be familiar
with and when she was a young woman
growing up she remembered watching on TV
lieutenant Uhura and she called out to
her mom mommy mommy mommy look at the TV
gather around and look there's a black
woman on TV and she is not a maid and
that helped inspire her to want to
become an actress and she went on to be
a great actress and being tons of movies
and just showing her a different path
now what's important to this story I
bring this up because you know I believe
you can learn from anybody I love
learning from men from women from white
from black from all sorts of different
countries and backgrounds and sexual
preferences and it doesn't matter to me
if I can learn from you I want to I want
to digest that message but I also fully
understand that especially at the
beginning people gravitate to learning
from people who look like them who are
from a simpler country who have similar
backgrounds who look like them and so
what I really wanted to do is you know
recognizing the importance of my channel
and seeing how for kids a lot of school
teachers are using my videos and sharing
it to their school as part of their
curriculum a lot of parents are sitting
down and watching my videos with their
kids and and looking at some of the
people we profiled it hasn't been as
diverse I would like it to be I think
there's an opportunity to make better
outreach so that when kids are watching
the show watching the channel there's
somebody who looks like them so that
they realize hey I can be an
entrepreneur too I can have success too
I don't need to be limited by the roles
that are currently out there and so my
first attempt with this was a girl wash
series and that came out recently and I
had some good success and I hope that
series continues and just showcasing
different women entrepreneurs and women
in different positions of power so that
the young girl
growing up can watch that and say hey I
could be a CEO I could be an
entrepreneur too and now I want to make
an outreach to the my friends in the
black community and the Latin community
I want to showcase the successful black
and Latin entrepreneurs as two different
series similar to what we did with
girlboss and what I need your help with
is coming up with the name I want to
pick something that signifies strength
and growth and entrepreneurship and
empowerment to that community but me not
being a part of the community I don't
want to pick the wrong name and so
girlboss is a trending hashtag
represents you know women empowerment
and I want to do the same thing for the
black and Latin communities and I want
your help what do we name the series and
so I want to give a quick shout out to
Devon Trish my Maria Rodriguez who
helped me come up with the initial kind
of road-test names we're looking at
black excellence for the Black Series
and vive for the Latin series I just
want to know your thoughts is there a
better name out there I'm not looking to
create my own trend I don't want to
create my own hashtag I want to jump on
one that is currently popular within
that community and lend my support to it
just like girlboss so I'd love to know
your thoughts I see these as a potential
monthly series so girl vos is a monthly
series you know black excellence or
whatever we call it as a monthly series
and then Viva or whatever we call it for
the Latin series once a month and so
really would appreciate suggestions on
what to call it
criteria one it's short like excellence
black excellence is four syllables
ideally something shorter but again
something that is is trending is already
a symbol of empowerment vive is okay
it's nice and short but it's just means
celebration it doesn't really have the
empowerment aspect of it so they're both
good roadmap names but I'm hoping we can
find something better and wanted to
engage you guys in the conversation if
you have a suggestion for me for what to
call it leave it down in the comments
below I'm really looking for
here we have to say thank you guys so
much for the support I really appreciate
it it means a lot to me and I hope these
new series take off thank you guys so
much enjoy the rest of Friday continue
to believe and whatever your one where
it is I'll see you soon
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core values is that we believe that
people with passion can not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details